okay why are you doing with the kids
what's going on an alleged kidnapper
caught on camera as Florida officers
make a quick Rescue of two young
children
step out of the car bro it happened on
October 10th in Hillsborough County
Florida just before seven o'clock that
evening Deputy Jonathan pasmino Alvarez
was flagged down by a distressed father
yes I know what that is I saw him
running this way the man told the
officer his children ages 4 and 8 were
taken when someone stole his truck just
minutes later Deputy pasmino Alvarez got
eyes on the vehicle stop the truck
now
pull into the parking lot
when the truck pulled over the deputy
began asking questions
he's not your car step out of the car
step out of the car bro
okay step out of the car the suspect
later identified as 37 year old Kevin
Smith continued to tell the deputy quote
it's not me
give me the car keys
body cam footage captures one of the
children saying the suspect is not his
father as the officer attempts to take
the man into custody is this yeah yeah
all right
step out of the car bro
Smith was arrested on the scene and
later charged with Grand Theft motor
vehicle and two counts of felony
kidnapping the children were not injured
in the incident and were safely returned
to their father for the latest
developments in this case and all things
True Crime stay with long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie